subindo aqui dá vontade de voltar atrás
e desistir mas eu paro respirou fundo e
pensa em seguir adiante e o que me
impulsiona isso a energia é a energia
que motiva me motiva cada dia a seguir
adiante com os meus planos com os meus
propósitos de vida e é isso que eu quero
deixar a mensagem para vocês todos nós
carregamos dentro do nosso coração algo
importante são os nossos sentimentos
perante pessoas perante situações
perante tudo aquilo que nós vivemos isso
nos contribuem para mover montanhas para
que nós consigamos planejar quem nós
somos quem nós queremos ser
faça de toda sua energia uma razão
construtiva
nós poderemos nos mover de forma
positiva ou de forma negativa perante
tudo aquilo que nos rodeia e que em
algum momento da nossa vida será
produzido nos deparamos com algumas
questões
afinal quem sou eu quem pretendo ser o
que realmente me traz a felicidade e
evoluir para que eu preciso evoluir
passei por muitos anos me questionando
por isso que me perguntando qual era a
razão para que eu estivesse vivo e sei
que em muitos casos
nós não chegamos a essas respostas nós
acabamos vivendo sem saber por qual
motivo
nós estamos aqui e as minhas respostas
foram através dos meus sonhos sonhos que
eu corri atrás
sonhos que eu busquei
realizá-los trouxe aqui uma frase de
sócrates conhece te a ti mesmo e
conhecerás universo e os deuses é aquela
questão de autoconhecimento como já foi
abordado
então aqui na minha palestra será um
complemento de tudo aquilo que vocês já
ouviram basicamente e daquilo que vocês
vivem que vocês poderão refletir 2010
2010 é um ano que marcou muito minha
vida é eu não trago fotos de período
anterior
tanto que a única foto que eu trouxe foi
a do meu registro geral
graças a deus ninguém consegue enxergar
mas quando olha pra ela eu vejo um
menino menina que nasceu de uma família
de não que não teve muitos muito poder
aquisitivo não teve muitas oportunidades
de graduação ou de uma estabilidade
profissional e financeira mas de uma
família onde sempre teve amor
compreensão respeito e harmonia
é nesse ambiente que eu cresci
mesmo enfrentando diversos problemas
dentre eles ambientes externos como o
bullying que eu sofri durante toda a
minha infância por ter um peso que não
era adequado perante a com a sociedade é
também sofri abuso sexual na infância
algo que meus pais estão na platéia e
hoje eles estão sabendo disso dentre
outros diversos problemas que eu
enfrentei 4as e que em 2010 junto ao
falecimento da minha avó que era
portadora de alzheimer nós cuidávamos
dela em período integral
eu descobri um quadro depressivo e desde
muito antes
hoje eu tentava cometer suicídio eu
descobri isso em 2010 junto com um
quadro de anorexia por conta de tudo
aquilo que hoje na infância porque aí
possam pensamos que as nossas ações
podem refletir de forma negativa na vida
das pessoas
no mesmo ano surgiu uma incrível
oportunidade da minha vida
uma organização chamada rota é que
oportunizou que eu conseguisse trabalhar
pela comunidade através de projetos
humanitários desenvolvimento pessoal
desenvolvimento cultural e o logo em
2012 eles me indicaram para o processo
de intercâmbio no qual do qual eu ganhei
uma bolsa integral de estudos
eu passei um ano na colômbia conheci
pessoas de diversos países
aprendi o pouco de cada idioma um pouco
de cada cultura um pouco desses costumes
meus pais ficaram aterrorizados um filho
com 16 anos saindo de casa explorar o
mundo mas fui essa missão embarquei e
foi o que trouxe grande enriquecimento
pra minha vida
foi lá que eu comecei a me descobri
descobrir que eu gostaria de trabalhar
com a saúde
definitivamente porém meu sonho seria
ser médico mas medicina é um curso muito
caro né por isso que exige um
investimento financeiro elevado e fugi
da minha realidade
então fui investigando outras
alternativas de como poderia alcançar
esse sonho mas nada vinha de resposta
mas eu sabia que eu queria salvar vidas
em 2014
foi um ano que marcou também a minha
vida porque foi a primeira vez que eu
2 amg e para algumas pessoas isso pode
ter significado nenhum porém para mim
era algo muito importante porque estava
contribuindo para salvar vidas
então foi a partir daí que comecei a
descobrir qual era a razão da minha
existência
muitas vezes nós nos perdemos através do
egoísmo através da do poder aquisitivo
do ter e esquecemos dos e esquecemos o
próximo e que devemos nos curvar por
alguém e que devemos tornar o nosso
tempo significativo para ajudar não só a
nós mesmos nossas ambições das nossas
realizações mas também pensando no
próximo
2016 foi o ano em que o mc a graduação
de farmácia com um é conseguir uma bolsa
integral de estudos estava no início de
graduação me sentindo muito
sobrecarregado infeliz pois não era
profissão almejada
mas hoje eu sinto imenso orgulho de
estar nessa carreira embora seja muitas
vezes vista como um profissional dos
valorizado porém é o caminho que deus ou
o universo colocou na minha vida me
disponibilizou que eu tenho orgulho de
seguir 2007 foi o ano que eu terminei um
relacionamento de uma forma muito ruim
muito negativa que durou quase três anos
então novamente eu vou ter um quadro
depressivo
até que eu recebi um comunicado
pra participar do desfile de 7 de
setembro na curitiba como todos os
intercambistas que estavam aqui através
do roteiro
então fui participei de toda aquela
energia novamente aquela energia que
retornava uma pessoa feliz uma pessoa
alegre e isso mostrou que eu deveria
voltar
a trabalhar pela comunidade e para isso
nós não precisamos apenas de uma
organização nós podemos fazer isso
diariamente mas o meu caso foi a foi
essa instituição que trouxe pra mim o
meu autoconhecimento que trouxe as
respostas que não encontrávamos pra mim
pra razão do meu existir
porém no mesmo ano iniciar um novo
relacionamento e sem saber
em poucos meses esse relacionamento ele
era abusivo
eu sofri violências de todas as formas
que vocês possam imaginar para não
instalar as humilhações ameaças e então
desencadeou novamente um quadro
depressivo um pouco ainda mais profundo
tentei novamente o suicídio e então foi
aí que eu comecei a despertar realmente
pra vida
antes eu buscava é complementar a minha
vida através da companhia de alguém mas
não através da minha própria essência da
minha pessoa através de ajudar o próximo
através dos meus familiares meus amigos
eu precisava ter alguém ao meu lado e
por conta disso eu acabei escolhendo
caminhos que quase levaram a um caminho
sem volta
então eu comecei a aplicar ainda mais a
outros projetos como o conselho regional
de farmácia que eu estive lá também
atuando como líder como diretor para
trabalhar com a comunidade
também fiz trabalho voluntário no em
2018 no asilo daqui da cidade é da
seleção vicente paulo foi o farmacêutico
é voluntário deles onde eu estive tendo
contato tanto com os idosos como também
com a todos os funcionários todos os
profissionais
caso não saiba hoje existe uma equipe
multiprofissional
então eu tive a possibilidade de
conhecer
os campos da saúde e também aprimorar os
meus conhecimentos e através desse
trabalho voluntário eu decidi
definitivamente retornará à família
rotária trazendo a juventude os
programas da juventude rotaract e
interact para castro novamente pra que
nós para que eu consiga através da
organização mostrar para a juventude que
existem caminhos de felicidade através
do seu trabalho humanitário do
desenvolvimento social é através de
todas essas desses projetos que eu
consigo trabalhar com algo significativo
e eu uso a minha energia não apenas pela
questão financeira não apenas para
conseguir um êxito profissional por um
currículo
eu uso a minha energia para trabalhar
também pela comunidade pois eu acredito
que tudo aquilo que eu recebo de
oportunidades tudo aquilo que a vida me
traz de positivo eu preciso compartilhar
eu preciso retribuir pois aqui dessa
vida
nós não levamos nada mas nós podemos
semear muitas plantinhas que trarão bons
frutos
nós não precisamos esperar grandes
coisas de pessoas que sejam esteja um
poder que está sobre nós mas nós podemos
mudar o mundo nós podemos transformar e
sobre você ocupar seu tempo com algo
significativo sobre você transformar sua
vida é você também ajudar alguém é você
também conseguir fazer algo construtivo
então essa mensagem que eu gostaria de
trazer para vocês uma reflexão que pode
ser direcionado em todos os campos da
vida profissional amoroso pessoal mas
principalmente trabalhar com a
comunidade
então vamos cada dia mais nos inspiramos
as pessoas que nós queremos ser as
pessoas que nós gostaríamos de ser
eu sou ala rodrigo soares tem 23 anos
muitos de vocês podem estar perguntando
o que o menino de 23 anos pode ter algo
positivo para trazer para nós mas talvez
as experiências de vida que o tij elas
possam contribuir para que cada um que
esteja que consiga refletir e buscar o
melhor de si e fazer algo bom para
alguém
hoje eu me sinto útil
eu reconheço qual é a minha missão e
reconhecendo quem eu sou
reconhecendo qual é o meu objetivo de
vida
eu consigo ter energia e forças para ir
além e também para motivar pessoas e
ajudá-las a em busca dos seus sonhos e
posso dizer que vivi uma fase de
renascimento
desde esses últimos anos principalmente
de 2008 para 2009 que foi o ano que
sofreu um grande impacto na minha vida
então sempre nós estaremos passando por
revoluções
nós devemos usá las positivamente com
equilíbrio mas com muita sabedoria
também eu explore os meus sonhos e são
eles que me impulsiona
são eles que me trazem ainda mais
energia e traz ainda mais motivação e
trazem poder de realizar tudo aquilo que
eu quero tudo aquilo que eu desejo
mas isso vem também do berço
nós não podemos esquecer com humildade a
nossa origem de onde nós viemos em quem
nós queremos e tudo é um complemento à
pessoa que nós somos e que nós seremos
só depende de nós e da nossa história
muito obrigado